good morning Millennials
good morning millennial Oh everyone aged
18 to 35 welcome Babbitt merge day was
right over that is right like literally
my Davis cookies yet forgot about March
even though like that was the biggest
deal that was the biggest deal that was
the whole day we die turn around
why turn on clear but turn it what is
turn around me just trust me where you
want me to turn just let me show me your
back come come I want to pat ourselves
on the back I want to Pat us on the back
because like I'm so impressed like with
just without like not only the selling
out because we sold out in presale which
is like a great problem to have there it
was a problem like only 10% of people
had access to merch and it sold out
right and we were saying we're like what
did he tell us how to pre-sell me we're
like well that's a great problem but
we'll get there when we get there but
then it happened in about nine minutes
I'm so crazy like me and Jackie we're
refreshing our Shopify apps such a great
moment for us and honestly Majora's la
who is our toaster slash our merch rep
our merch account executive and she was
just on it she's like my boss thinks
you're gonna break Shopify and we were
like yes we are bad and then five
o'clock came around and we were like
restocking every five minutes and the
toaster is just the power of the toast
never ceases to amaze right now the
merge site is still live if you didn't
get what you wanted to get pretty much
everything is there except for a mug and
pillow but the pop sockets are there
everything is there about the show shop
morning to us calm if you didn't get
what you so because in a few hours we
are going to close shop to get ready for
drop numbers and yeah we're gonna
fulfill and now that everyone got like
their basic needs now I want to do like
Kylie drops like minimum amounts of the
sickest [ __ ] and if you don't get it
sorry bro
sucks you know what I mean no totally I
got the basics like everyone deserves a
t-shirt and a mug with them on it
totally but basic necessities but now
sick [ __ ] bro I have some ideas brewing
and don't worry because don't worry be
monkey
we'll be coming out every course and
either we just have to check the
legality on that because so far we have
only been making much of like things
that we own like we own can't agenda but
I feel like so many people make this
like write the same [ __ ] on t-shirts for
Tuesday nah Netflix and chill said you
fund a hot mom jug mom unicorn lover
it felt really good to get everyone what
they wanted like this was a year in the
making and honestly everything happens
for a reason because if we were able to
have gotten merch out when the breath
was on like it wouldn't have been nearly
as epic and also as like I'm fulfilling
on a personal level because it just
wouldn't have been ours yeah we did a
patreon episode yesterday right after we
launched merch it's all about like the
business side of the toast it's actually
really interesting especially on merch
day it was just so full circles so full
circle we kind of pull back the curtain
to show you like how the toast runs on a
business level so if you are interested
in the business woman special I would
become a patreon member and listen to
that episode we owe you one more episode
before the end of the month so that you
have something to listen to I'm your
Labour Day drives so that'll be coming
at you shortly and a lot of people are
not some questions if they could make
returns before their order is fulfilled
and I don't really know because we don't
do that but I've heard that Shopify has
been really helpful if you just email
customer service like asking just what's
your size oh yeah and did you see the
thing about the shipping yeah that
everything that was bought after a
pre-sale so anything you bought in a
restock is gonna take a few days to
fulfill so it'll probably ship out
around September 10 yeah also um that's
way faster than Kylie at Kanye and
Ariana so please like don't complain
so please guys we're on it like we're on
it just like please okay yeah thank you
mm-hmm anyways I can't believe but it's
only Tuesday
this is no longest week of life
yesterday was the longest day of my life
no same I mean three huge things
happened for me yesterday okay my merch
sold out where's my hours I guess
whatever virus I guess we just put I
guess whatever we're sold out - I picked
a color scheme no you didn't yes I good
I'm going Greg you are yeah okay we'll
say no I'm doing I'm ordering the couch
when I leave here I'll call the place
and three what was three just you know
some good business developments
personally in otherwise that's great
also Taylor Owen just suggested for a
teacher instead of don't worry be monkey
don't worry be toasty with you and let's
do a picture of a monkey it's just I'm
very interested to find out because
we've you know sales call later today
what products were the most popular
because
I think that initially when we were like
designing stuff I like I think I would I
would want from like a show that I liked
and like yes obviously like a shirt that
says the morning shows on it but also
like more creative dynamic design stuff
that it's like if you're a toaster you
get it but if you're not a toaster it's
not like what the hell is that look you
can borrow right if it's a friend's or
something right but I found that the
stuff with the toasty vibe and the
toasty logo was more popular than just
like the universally cool items you know
totally so interesting so interesting
but now we know and we'll give you more
toast centric items yeah
also the pop sockets were the number-one
hit because like those are just a
necessity and they were just I think so
reasonably priced I mean no I'm like a
merch kind of sore because I've been
buying everyone's merch and like the
Kanye merch was so expensive and took
over two months to ship Ariana I still
haven't gotten it like I literally so
not I have a gotten my I got his woman
shirt I bought a Mason Ramsey merch and
it literally came in a week good for him
he's running a tight ship over there did
you see some of the comments Carly
Pierce made about Mason Ramsey I didn't
see the comments what did she say look
maybe to chew sure it was in a news
blast I got just hang on feel free to uh
saying well I well I look forward to
saying wow I thought you'd never ask
I did a musical Monday SoulCycle
yesterday and it was amazing per usual
but he played the Sun will come out
tomorrow and it was just if you've never
spun to that ride thus was did of a beat
behind though no it was just it was like
for a it was for recovery after arms and
it's just like take it at your own speed
so I was doing double time just cuz like
a knee pumps me up and it was really
nice moment okay this is what she said
this is for the Chicago splash written
by Beth Delaney with people like Mason
Rams to be coming overnight successes do
you regret that you didn't have a viral
moment that granted you that instant
fame because Carly parce has been like
out here on these streets pounding the
pavement for years she said and
especially in regards to that situation
I believe those are flashes in the pan
and those aren't careers quite frankly I
think when you work for it from the
ground up and experience everything and
put in the blood sweat tears I think
that makes you gracious I think that
makes it authentic and I think that is
ultimately what sets you up for true
career I don't just agree but like my
son Ramsay has a trip no I don't
disagree with that but Mason Ramsay is
the exception to that because not only
is he a flash in the pan but it's like
that flash was so talent
worthy of like a career in country music
that the that he's flashing left right
and center and I love them both and I'm
not taking so I'm not taking this feud
and I just feel like any like Mason
Ramsey is legit as hell of course you
know he's like so goddamn talented I
know I'm gracious and cute and has no
clue what's going that's two McGraw he
has no clue what's going on like when
you see him he has no clue that's all
what do you see that video of him
dancing to his song at the Teen Choice
Award or the Nick whatever Awards he was
at and like he literally doesn't know
that there's anyone around him in here
like him in his music its self-awareness
that he lacks right because he's a child
and he should be and children should not
have self-awareness I agree that's where
you like learn who you are totally and
so Mason I love you we support you know
you will always have to see I hope you
do have like a little bit of a fall from
grace so that you'll find like I'm on
our show that's like at the level you're
right now you're too good for us I
understand but maybe you know maybe a
couple years but he's going on tour with
Chris Lane we will be there especially
the one from about her you know he's the
one who went on The Bachelor and started
DMing all the girls I mean honestly I
can't anymore people don't do that and I
can't believe none of the girls took him
up on it I just have to say I did not
watch back to him paradise for another
week I really I did my best to try and
watch it for you guys but like every
time I let go on Twitter and I see all
these like [ __ ] basic [ __ ] just
like tweeting about leo and like I just
can't first of all there's two types of
tweets when it comes to at bachelor in
paradise
people who just like try and like
screenshot funny things and like be
hilarious and like go virus right I'm
like please and then people who like
analyze it from like a female modern
feminist point of view and it's like
[ __ ] you are watching the wrong show
like people who are just like looking
for meaning and like cultural like
progressivism in a show that's literally
about a guy dating 500 girls like wrong
show wrong network right you know I
totally string them on it's like someone
you know and here comes our classic male
chauvinists yeah that's like please
[ __ ] this is not the platform like do
your good work somewhere else like I
just hate when people like trying to ply
the batch or something that it's not
and it's never pretended to be it's it
is
what it is it's not pretending to be
like the next frontier or anything
sometimes we get some girls who like
really post modern feminism that's what
they're saying
postmodern what does that mean this is
modern to postmodern as a future I don't
understand that what so they're really
just looking to deep into it and I've
been watching because it's actually the
perfect show for me right now because I
can't really focus if I'm watching
anything and last time it really was
like feeling queasy and I'm not sure why
so guys I was feeling queasy as how like
I've just been feeling queasy ho
problems I feel like I'm always feeling
queasy anyways so I was enjoying it and
it things are evolving and moving and
it's like just so funny their whole
formulas like two people are getting
along let's bring in the person who said
they wanted to meet right and it's like
do you guys not want happy couples and
happy relationship though they don't
also Connor showed up last night and
like he's a toaster and I love him and
he goes out with crystal who by the way
is the MVP of paradise she is doing
everything right
first of all her looks are on point like
her hair is oh he's in like a cute
headband because it's so dumb huh cuz
it's hot and like her bathing suit she's
like looking sort of retro and I'm
loving it and I mean Chris is the worst
person in paradise hands down I don't
know how he became like the king of the
boys there's Chris um big smile
Eddie from friends yes I know he
literally hates me you know you have a
sunset I watched he has decided that he
is going to be the moral compass of
Perrineau he decided that he is the
queen bee of paradise and that like Oh
any time Chris is feeling a certain way
like all the boys come around him and
I'm like this guy is a loser he's the
biggest [ __ ] Maria Menounos
it's like he's such a loser and honestly
and you know I have so many thoughts and
I guess we'll get to paradise later but
here are my thoughts Chris is a loser he
referred to himself in the third person
we're talking to cause I'm done I'm done
no one picked up on it cuz he referred
to himself by his last night he's like
you're really gonna leave the rad
because this I think it's like rad one
you remember um what was that kid's name
in high school he was always like I
don't remember his name buddies he's
like tar no loves this suppose his name
david turn off ski oh yeah he would be
like tar no ton of rules it's like who
is that I hate when people do that yeah
it was really bad but it went unnoticed
and crystal is just a class act because
she has it
with Chris Connor said she came there
for Connor and Connor came there for her
but she's already met Chris so Connor is
like talking her and she was like I want
to be honest with you like I really was
excited to meet you but I'm like kind of
smitten with Chris right now so I want
to see that through well a boy would
never do that
and then crystal tells Chris that she's
like said that to him and Connor still
wants to go out with her knowing all of
this so she goes out with him because
like she came here explore this option
so we don't know who she's gonna give
her rose to but she is doing everything
right and I can tell that she's getting
along with all of the girls and I'm
loving her honestly she doing the Lord's
work if she just gave it to Connor just
to that [ __ ] who'd go home no I can't
look at him anymore but this is my exact
point and that's what people are always
especially in the morning toasters
Facebook group which you should try it's
people are always like oh Jordan Jordan
Jordan it's like I'm absolutely done
liking and hating the people that
production decides to like an hey like
they wanted to see Chris so I mean did
and they wanted to say Jordan to me dude
I'm like now especially to meet those
people in real life like Olivia Freitas
the best example she couldn't been like
a nicer girl like I'm done just
believing what Elon and Mike Fleiss want
me to leave like Crystal's crazy okay I
believe didn't know I'm like no she's
not she's cool as hell Jordan honestly I
met him couldn't be nicer like I'm done
listening to the producers also
everything that Jordans doing is like so
understandable and relatable and
honestly like jenna is the one like
after last night she was being like so
wishy-washy but I also think that
editing made it look even worse than it
was but like he's like gung-ho for her
and it's not like he's like he could
easily when he saw Jenna with someone
else like ran back to Annalise who like
can't catch a man and it's so totally
hot and like gotten her rose but instead
like he's like I'm here for Jenna like
I've never experienced all that first
sight but I think this is the closest
thing to it and if he doesn't get her
rose he doesn't want to be there and
that's what paradise is all about not
like it is about you know being open to
making connections but it's also about
like being in a relationship and I just
want to say Astrid and Kevin are my
favorite couple in Paradise history
first of all he is so like so is she
I could die and she is gorgeou and like
in every single angle every light every
makeup no makeup look like she crushes
it and the two of them together are just
so cool like they are the cool people
and ice and like people should be
circling around then which I think that
they are but they weren't ending like
it's Chris that's yeah and he used that
like the sweetest thing to her last
night he was like he couldn't believe
that like she was with him and he
like he was like I want you to date
other guys so that like you like me more
you know like she started crying cuz she
was like I don't want to date other
people and why would you want me to and
hopefully this is just too good to be
true like you're my dream girl do you
want to be with no no if you watch the
whole thing please I'm trying to break
up with her no he was just like he can't
believe that it was so good you know and
so because also he said when he was on
The Bachelorette like he 106 and thought
he was getting engaged and like that was
heartbreaking
then when Susan was gone he's from
Canada Oh then when he met Ashley I
everything was great on winter games
they got in gate or no they didn't get
engaged I'm sorry but they left together
and then he was like he was like all
this [ __ ] that happened after Instagram
all this stuff I'm 35 I don't care about
any of that it was it was an amazing
moment and then she was like she
understood why he was like pulled back
for a second and she was like I don't
think he understands that like yes I'm
like his dream girl but I feel like I'm
so lucky to have met him too that's
great I love them so I'd always be lucky
like feel lucky to be with the one that
you're is right I hope that they got
engaged and I'm obsessed with them um
did you watch all the boys I've loved
before
no because of merge' did you watch
preppie connection no because of March
Jackie I didn't get home till 8:30 and
then I had to watch paradise and I
caught up on Kardashians does that count
for something no you we're so delayed
with the stupid movie of the week don't
want to all the boys Ella before watch
preppie connection I well that's what my
day is wide open okay merch J what do
you want me to do I know business never
sleeps never ever see as my as my
entrepreneurial brother says Mark Cuban
says entrepreneurialism never sleeps JC
say that also for our next merch shop
we're making a briefcase that says the
McKenzie file for all of you uh working
people out there totally like that was
the idea we came up on the patreon
episode and we were starkly laughing but
like people to really use briefcase yeah
well it'll be like limited edition yeah
it's like a collector's item
no everything from now on it's like
special edition like if you don't got it
sell them on eBay you know that's what
we thought yesterday and then we were
like let's just keep let's make all the
money we can because we want you guys to
get that what you wanted like I didn't
like oh I wanted the mug yeah and get it
know like that we enemy wouldn't comply
yeah we were conservative with her and
now that everyone got it and I'm happy
but now it's like drop like a note no no
warning just like literally we're gonna
be on the show be like oh by the way the
sickest submerge collection just drop
bro shot Morton chose calm like epic
like only like 100 of each you know
we'll talk about that anyways are you
ready to get into the fast
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast question I guess ok first
up we have an array of news per look of
course this is the most rounded
well-rounded showing literally shyam me
and my body reflect the the
well-roundedness we are well-rounded
mentally and physically of course uh
Katy Perry denies that dr. Luke raped
her in the deposition Katy Perry denied
the dr. Luke raped her in a recently
unsealed deposition from the producers
2017 lawsuit against Ke$ha a report said
no Perry or PI when asked if the music
producer raped her according to Us
Weekly absolutely not she added when
asked if he quote sexually assaulted her
dr. Luke's lawyers claimed Ke$ha lied in
the text to Lady Gaga when she said dr.
Luke real name Lucas Scott Wald raped
Perry in an apparent attempt to boost
her own sexual assault claims when asked
in court at the statement that Ke$ha
made about her and dr. Luke was fault
Perry replied yes ma'am so explain to me
text messages were released between
Kesha and Lady gaga that were part of
the courts where Ke$ha texted Lady Gaga
that dr. Luke raped Katy Perry
then Katy Perry had to testify and she
says it was not happen and in the
deposition she said that - she yeah and
that Cassius was gonna have such a pit
about this story because no matter who's
lying like it's terrible either like
Katy Perry's a victim in denial and like
that gives me the biggest cut ever or
like Kesha is a full-blown liar but like
what who's who I mean it was lying
because it changes everything this is so
weird
the plot thickens and also like I just
still can't believe that this case has
not been settled you know I'm almost
glad that it wasn't yet because like I
want dr. Luke's name to be he to keep me
coming up in the news with the word
right next to it no but like are getting
a job now but he's still working like
until this the nail is in the coffin on
dr. Luke's career and like something
like someone takes these claims
seriously like he's still working like
he's still making music he's still
making money did you see that louis c.k
just like first show last night kid
after he admitted he like pled guilty to
five counts of sexual assault and like
he got a standing ovation losers stood
up for him I don't I don't know I only
saw the title when I was looking for
honestly this town makes me sick
this town or bar the pounds yeah that
except for Cleveland of course and
that's wrong Miami - um no just like no
Miami's pretty seems like I'm disgusted
do you know what I mean and it's like
like it's just so like classic like a
man gets to like literally admit that
he's sexually assaulted five people and
like he hits a standing ovation they'll
get for it Mel Gibson's standing ovation
at the Oscars like Mel Gibson in daddy's
home - he was mm-hmm it's just like sick
it's a sick world that we live in and
I'll be talking about this all the time
and it's like what's it gonna like
there's no amount of change that's ever
gonna change and mark my words what's
goes on Harvey Weinstein will be back at
work in ten years I'm serious that's how
disgusting Hollywood is they pretend to
care they don't they yeah and it's like
Kevin Spacey on house of cards I saw
this morning that like the new storyline
has come out about the season of house
of cards cuz obviously Kevin Spacey's
not in it and it's just so reminded me
it's like he was at the helm of this
show while everyone knew they knew how
horrible he was and it's like they
pretend now like oh we didn't know but
you know know everyone knows everything
it was just like then something happens
they all pretend to be shocked but
please honey disgusting but even at the
Oscars like this year even after Harvey
Weinstein even after everyone's up there
like talking about me to like talk about
like gender equity it's like there are
still people in the audience who are
criminals sexual criminals and you know
that silly how about one of you stands
up there and calls them out you know
who's a true warrior Terry Crews yes I
absolutely love him and Seth MacFarlane
yes in different ways in different ways
so like Terry Crews is like one of the
only people who spoken up like as a man
that he was a victim of sexual assault
in Hollywood he you know there's so many
more but like mad bro manly like you
can't say bro you can't read man like
you can and Terry Crews is cool about it
and I like him I love him me too like I
mean in general in white chicks like you
saw my heart but and he and he never
took it he never gave it back like my
heart still belongs to him and I yes
yeah I think he's honestly what one of
the most underrated under radiant
underrated like male comic actors in of
our time
I totally agree so funny he's so funny
and
so cute anyways we'll keep you posted on
this dr. Luke catch a story I I mean I'm
not taking any cell like it's not my
business really uh but hopefully the
truth will come to light everything
that's done in the dark eventually comes
to light so true okay next up in today's
edition of what's going on with Elon
Musk Elon Musk is skipping Burning Man
this year that's major for him that's a
wise decision is Burning Man Elon Musk
who has had a tough year
or really just like few months is not
expected to speak up Burning Man the
temporary city in the Nevada desert
dedicated to art music sex and drugs the
tesla creator went every year for nine
years but this year the SEC is
reportedly investigating Tesla after
Musk's recent tweet about taking the
company private which led to wild swings
in the price of its stock like what's
wrong with that though um it's like
intentionally disrupting the market like
I don't know without like it's just like
specula Kuenn Kylie said whether the F
was SEC investigating her Kylie doesn't
work for snapchat actually I think that
they do I think they do pay her also
they all the Kardashians to say on
snapchat
yeah but Kylie definitely not Kourtney I
don't know last I caught up on
Kardashian's last night and she like
took the picture of Kendall's hat on
snapchat and then I'm sure she like
uploaded it ins like they all stick with
snapchat interesting it's yeah it is
this is honestly like no matter what
puff from there on it was an alien's
people are gonna watch it so like it
must be nice not have to worry about
that right musk who has admitted to
taking ambien to help with him sleep but
denied he was stoned on pot when he
posted the fateful tweet stoned on pot
like please
Fuli stoned on pot Candace like this was
written literally by like an 87 year old
first grader yeah he does look like him
of totally areas he looks like Elon Musk
no Elon Musk skipping Burning Man I mean
he can't afford to be seen partying this
year with 70,000 revelers who end up who
end the week with a giant
Burning Man bonfire I mean I'm just like
I feel like Burning Man is where Elon
goes to like get all of his next best
ideas
well cause like you hallucinate on drugs
like you get inspiration in here among
other creatives here's the thing I truly
I cannot think of a place I would rather
go less
Burning Man I agree and I think about
this all the time and I don't understand
how it's so cool cuz like we had a
friend who used to go with like so
basically if you go just like a regular
you're not a celebrity like there's no
Wi-Fi there's nowhere to sleep you sleep
in like a tent on the floor in the dirt
and like there's no use a shower and
like it was like barter first and buddy
yeah alright there's no money at Burning
Man like if you want to buy a snack
you have to barter like you've taken a
massage yeah it's very weird but then
how did that person that you're getting
a snack from habits if I brought it with
them
well I so bring your own snacks to iOS
but like if you're with celebrities like
there's like certain camps that I like
have Wi-Fi in like like glamping almost
yeah and like even that sounds horrible
right and I can't believe celebrities
who are like such divas like would go to
that charity Shelton but what do you do
there is it a music festival it's an
arts music festival and like you have a
lot of sex and you do a lot of drugs and
like I think it's like very orgy you try
something what itinerary like there's
all these art installations and you're
like on drugs so that takes up a lot of
time that sounds so [ __ ] boring I
mean yeah like not not anything like
camp toast no we have a full itinerary
packed with fun and good tickets it's
the bright cantos is the antithesis of
Burning Man
yeah like if you are anti Burning Man
camp Trust is a place for you like you
will be fed multiple times a day and you
don't to barter for anything you just
have to buy one ticket on Eventbrite go
to our Instagram and click the get
tickets loud link password is premium
all caps like you'll be fine
alcohol will be served for a furry full
itinerary with activities that capture
the flag town show sing-alongs bonfires
minimal visit honestly as much physical
activity as you want to put into it I
want to I want to do everything like I
personally will need a golf cart just to
like you know go around the campgrounds
because I want to visit everyone gonna
supervise I want to supervise that every
activity and I just really feel like
walking from the volleyball court to the
basketball court seems like a long walk
but put in as much as you want you don't
like if you want to sleep in do it like
I want to take a golf cart from like jet
skiing to the ropes course you guys out
if you need if you're looking for me
I'll be at the ropes course all day yeah
actually that like there's like this
obstacle course it's like they did on OC
it's called the ice
yeah but what how many think you think
it is in the air I have no don't do that
think I think of it like how many rulers
stacked up I think it's like 50/50 max
and there's a big rock climbing wall and
it's all in the lake and it's so pretty
zipline and there's a swing there's a
zipline yeah the zipline is across the
lake it's new what high you go like you
going but you woods in the link no you
land at the ropes course from across the
lake it's amazing oh my god that's new
that wasn't there the Giant Swing you
know where they waist you up all the way
and then you pull the that's really the
scariest thing of all time crazy they
literally like they tell you to keep
going and they'll pull you up like you
need your enough to pull you you go up I
think you can go up there as like I
stopped it like it's a hundred feet but
you can say stop whenever and then you
click this thing and you yourself you
drop and you're in a harness so you just
keep swinging but like that drop is like
your belly drops into your ass right
it's like if you've never experienced it
before just go up there yeah it's called
the giant pit and honestly like the
living conditions are just there the
bare necessities and more like of course
like the bare necessities the simple
bare necessities bug what without your
worries and your smile I forget I got
their necessities confused with the
Charmin Bears who are always wiping
their houses
hey snitch can you do me a favor so we
put the Eventbrite URL in the Instagram
I in the YouTube and in the YouTube and
in the YouTube stream I emailed it
yesterday
aking insurance burgers keep lining
hello Wow insurance for CT BlueCross
BlueShield like it's and you get so many
of those I get like your scars she's
running out like you don't even have a
license
it's your refrigerator running well you
better go get it and like I block the
callers just because like that that
can't hurt but it definitely doesn't
help no it does nothing and I feel like
it's only recently cut that's become
like a thing in the past like maybe here
two years where everyone just get call
it gets calls and on top and they're so
smart I've started to get phone numbers
they see that little thing here is that
like I have like two numbers different
than my phone number like who who is the
same phone number as me right a lot less
Jennifer from Blue Cross solution it
sends [ __ ] your car turns and I
always talk to them back I'm like I
don't even have my license and they just
keep going because it's not a main
machine it's an unmanned machine I like
getting a person and then I get real
mean I'm like where did you get this
number
you know this is illegal we're moving
from your Call list
at this very moment I just had to like
Shannon beador you did I'm so good I'm
so behind on OC at my show in Raleigh I
like tried to do it Shannon beador
my friend Margo fish just the most
amazing Shannon beador and impersonate
she's like and she sounds just like
Shannon she's like David David they're
being mean to me David it's so good like
that was bad and I tried to do it at my
Raleigh show and I felt like everyone
would know what I was talking about and
they're like who is who's the impression
but Zac what like it obviously wasn't
good it was like this Margo I'm gonna
make my real fish make a video for us
it's so good mine was like David David
the ring made to me David
that's like here Broadway for ya $8.00
that is my Broadway voice any dollars
down the drain
yeah it's like I haven't boys been like
I think like if I ever make it to like
50 attack and here being like I don't
know every like these Broadway actors
are like every like just speaking like
takes all the energy they're like how
could you do this to me David
it's really good oh we're only on Story
number three okay next up CMA Award
nominees are out Chris Stapleton leaves
the Awards as you carry underwear it
Underwood and Keith Urban earned
nominations also according to snitch to
kill a sweet Oh
so we're which um acronym is this CMA
this is odd this is legit yes exactly we
gotta make plans
I know but the nominations are coming
out so early like considering it's to
November nobody got any plans no we're
going we're hitting up what are we
Kaitlyn Bristowe sister-in-law member oh
yeah yeah with her yeah okay so
Nashville's brightest and newest stars
are smiling big Luke Bryan dan + Shay
and Sugarland announce the nominations
for the 2018 Country Music Association
Awards Tuesday live on GMA from New
York's Times Square
Chris Stapleton leads the pack of CMA
nominees with 5 mods including
Entertainer of the Year single of the
year and record of the year following
the release of his album from a room vol
2 Jason Aldean and Keith Urban each
earned three nominations with both stars
competing and Stapleton for Entertainer
of the Year meanwhile Carrie Underwood
who will also be co-hosting the
star-studded soiree garnered two
nominations
including female vocalist of the year so
here are the nominations Entertainer of
the Year doing it like you're on TV and
it's 6:00 a.m. and they're making you do
it here are the nominees the NAM are the
nominees for Entertainer of the Year
Jason Aldean Luke Bryan Kenny Chesney
Chris Stapleton Keith Urban Wow all men
and female vocalist of the year even
though there's also male vocalist of the
year what was one you said entertaining
so yeah should be Telesis used to win
that all the time yeah also Garth Brooks
but yeah who do you think should be
Entertainer of the Year
read it again Jason Otto you're a
simpleton he's always it's so weird cuz
I love country music and I just I like
the songs of his that are popular but I
don't like go hard for him I don't go
hard for me either
I just think he's supremely talented and
I think like like I mean okay here's the
thing
what does Entertainer mean people who
entertain because then it's like Luke
Bryan but like Luke Bryan is no it's
lyrical genius or like you know the song
the songbird of our generation like what
does Entertainer mean like you put on
the most shows you see the most people
or is it like you're the most vocally
lyrically talented I think it's like I
mean it's just like breaking in the
fun's songs it's probably like that's
why they keep nominating Luke Bryan
Jason Aldean Blake Shelton even though
like they're really not like the most
talented yeah they just they're on
American Idol and the boys like
Instagram followers and they sell the
most tickets stratosphere yeah female
vocalist of the Year Kelsea Ballerini
Miranda Lambert Maren Morris Kacey
Musgraves and Carrie Underwood we do it
again female vocalist of the year yeah
Kelsea Ballerini Miranda Lambert Maren
Morris Kacey Musgraves Carrie Underwood
I mean obviously Miranda Lambert's gonna
win because she has some in with every
country music award like organization
but honestly like this was the year of
Kacey Musgraves Kacey or Marin should
win because like she brought so much
shine to country music with Marian
released an album no no it was last year
yeah so it's hard to win like of the
year with with one even though it was
the biggest song of all time but her
Marin Mars two albums coming out and
it'll be her year next year this was a
year of Kacey Musgraves even though she
really is not technically country these
days she's more alternative yeah her
first album same trailer different Park
was like so country and
so good so was pageant materials like a
little more alternative but Gold's an
hour it's like legit the most beautiful
album of all time I'll never get sick of
listening to it and it's not really
country I hope she wins the male
vocalist of the Year Derrick's Bentley
snitch Naruto oh he's gonna win Thomas
Rhett oh man Keith Urban Thomas Rhett
might win yeah I think Thomas Rhett
might win - or like darks I feel like
he's been like working hard no see it's
just so weird because everyone's like
perception of country music is so
different I like the real hardcore
country fans that like love Luke combs
love Chris Stapleton they don't like
like Jason Aldean Blake Shelton they
think they're like [ __ ] no I don't
think so I think the real hardcore
country fans like love Jason Aldean and
who are you just talking about Luke
Bryan with Bryan but like Luke Combs
technically and uh Chris Stapleton are
like newbies
yes it's very similar to but Chris
Ableton's have been out here for like a
few years now yeah but Jason Medina and
Luke Bryan have been doing this for like
10 years yeah yeah yeah so it's just
like a different level yeah um no if I
really like Luke comes out to win
everything I know like I feel like he
might be too green you know ya know to
be like but it really was like who are
the most impressive year Luke Holmes
he's shot to stardom
that's impressive I think Thomas red
he's like so mainstream - yes and him
and his wife like they just kill it
right vocal group of the year Lady
Antebellum we know who's gonna win lanco
Little Big Town Midland Old Dominion
little big towns gonna win but honestly
the greatest love story ever told by
lanolin Oh Midland Blanco or I get Lenco
and ultimate in confused old dominions
really good Oh
Old Dominion is um take you straight
somewhere you didn't know what's it
called
what like the song where it's like he
needed someone to show you around they
do Britain in the stars and Margo take
someone to show you around okay Margo
Google Old Dominion take someone to show
you someone to show you around and then
like truck Vocal Duo of the year brother
size and shape brothers not born Ganon
che Florida Georgia line Maddie and Tay
Sugar Land a Qi Dan and chai though
we've sugar Lin's only two people I
guess so I feel like someone trapped out
where did you find it
are you thinking of I by the way that
lyric doesn't exist
oh but I'm just gonna pull up their most
popular songs and you'll see which one
yeah it's like um if you need somebody
to show you around I know some
day is that I know somebody yeah who's
that I don't think it's old somebody
with the jacked-up truck sitting right
outside truck told you if you're ready
to roll then I'm ready to ride does he
let them but it's such a good song with
something as a broken heart
oh yeah but what who sings my song can
you repeat the lyrics and it's called
know somebody okay snitches on the case
snitch can low - low cash yes and that's
what you think you thought that was
lanco yes oh stop okay that's very
confusing yeah Vocal Duo that should be
an interesting matchup because this was
the year of dan + Shay but Florida
Georgia line like they sell out stadiums
they're like Taylor Swift level like
they're making so much money so I don't
know new artists of the year this is our
category okay we should be the one I get
on this yes
it's Carly parson there yeah oh [ __ ]
Mesa Rosie no no kidding okay let me
think two seconds no Lauren Alaina okay
Luke Combs that's so weird that he's the
artist and no male vocalist there but so
that's why he won't win male vocalist
but I'm here of them win new artist I'd
be so happy
Chris Jansen Midland or Brett young
who's also great but not as great midlet
everyone loves Midland and they're good
and we met then they were so cool and
like interesting looking I just don't
haven't heard their music like it's not
shove down popular country they know
their one song I don't have a drinking
problem and I have a drinking solution
yeah I think that that's obviously Luke
ohms is category to take but honestly
good for Lauren Alaina for getting there
I mean I would be so happy if she won a
single of the year broken halos by Chris
Stapleton
drinking problem by Midland drowns the
whiskey by Jason Aldean meant to be
bebe Rexha Florida Georgia line tequila
tannin a tequila Jenna Jeff yeah
like honestly that song to fight country
music and it's like the biggest song of
ever its unbuilding it at every show
because every time I take a sip of my
drink which is to kill on my Quinta and
like no matter where I am in the country
people know it yeah I'll bet you they
know it better and like Nashville but
still and then last one will do is album
of the year which is from a room volume
to Chris Stapleton
golden hour Kacey Musgraves graffiti you
Keith Urban life changes Thomas Rhett
the mountain darks Bentley
I really hope Kacey Musgraves wins but I
feel like Thomas actually Chris tables
him will probably win yeah no there's
always like I call it the Slumdog
Millionaire like because of the first
award show I ever really watched in full
was the year some dog millionaire and
they want every rewarding ahead and
scene and I'm like what the hell and
they had seen it and then I saw it I'm
like oh this is the most amazing movie
of all time right when the guy writes
the letter on the mirror of like the
answer that was so crazy yeah he was
lying right yeah [ __ ] I have to be the
next host movie of the week if we ever
got there
okay next story a little business and
the FDA is just come in for Jul obvious
Oh nobody's cigarette popular among
teens is being investigated by the FDA
the Food and Drug Administration says it
is preparing to launch a campaign to
discourage teens from using e-cigarettes
also known as vaping the FDA is also
investigating the marketing strategies
and impact of several vaping products
including the most popular a cigarette
jool which is estimated to make up 72
percent of the e-cigarette market the
agency says its new campaign is just
part of its effort to find out why
e-cigarette use is rampant among
teenagers and how to stop it at the same
time parents are launching their own
effort and asking why the government
isn't doing more reports CBS News Anna
Werner wait that is so crazy because I
think about this all the time because
like literally everyone in the world
Jules they do all join the day they
drool at night it's so crazy there
Jackie makes that's called their
literary smoke --usb and like like it's
like you can charge your jewel in my in
my charging box in the mall
we're in the wall you're smoking and
Alec you're smoking what's in this
battery by electron you're smoking
battery no it's really crazy but the
more that I think about it like I it's
Jula must be like a billion dollar
company like how did that happen because
these things have been around for a
while yeah Jules are just like well made
I guess and they're you know what it is
it's like a lot of girls use it we're
like girl like I feel like smoking and
like vaping is much more like a male
thing and now like every girl is smoking
a jewel yeah and it's like less like I
guess gross it's considered less gross
than smoking like cigarettes for sure so
I'm just like torn here cuz like even
though you are smoking protons right I'm
torn air just like good on Joule for
like making a company but like and now
the government is gonna like trying to
do and then well the government is
pissed because a lot of teens are
smoking and it seems as though they've
been they've known that teens are buying
jewels and
our marketing towards teens which is
like a little [ __ ] up that is [ __ ]
up but I've not in the dual commercial
me neither
we're like a plus a third post or
anything yeah what kind of marketing
just drills you how do we get it on it I
don't know I think it's just I came to
which is emotive word of mouth yeah I'll
come of anything for for the right
amount I don't think I would really it's
like a bad example I think but like
here's the thing like MTV and you know
the FDA they're they're out here in
these streets I try and get people to
stop smoking cigarettes and they'll stop
at nothing you know
like their commercials like they're
don't care who they have to like exploit
like they'll stop at nothing so cool so
you can't like take away every vice from
every person so what is so wrong with
the jewels that you want to stifle then
like guys they're replacing cigarettes
isn't that a win I guess are you why are
you looking at me like that Margo I
thought you were trying to get my
attention that's like did you text she's
just so interested by the conversation
that we're having Margo's embarrassed
you Joel Margo hey do your friends yes
like everyone and today jewel like
socially like I parties or like in class
just socially at parties the people who
like jewel in the library I don't know
so this are insane I think they put it
back in their computer to charge I
between each oh my god smoking their
computer that's so funny
that's like the one crazy part like
jewel I mean it's really cool what
they're doing and they're like not that
terrible but it's just weird and there
was like one instance of someone's true
like exploding on their face like one
freak accident yeah I read that in my
Instagram story once like I literally
like I think I like how to jewel in my
hand I like was at a party and I wanted
to be cool which it's not but legit the
messages of hatred cannellini yeah like
I think because anytime you post
something that has like a cigarette in
it like people go nuts like and
rightfully so because smoking is
disgusting and it kills you and like it
was that level that's so crazy because
like right now there is no evidence of
like time from this boil they say that a
jewel pod like that is like the flavor
that you put in which can last you a
really long time it's like a full pack
of cigarettes oh how long does it last
though it depends if you're doing in the
library no but still better than
cigarettes I think I
I [ __ ] I've had a little jewel here and
there when I'm gonna party like but not
like you have your own no I don't have
my own that charge is in my wallet
no no but like sometimes you know the
jewel is making its rights 1111 [ __ ]
wish I hope everyone stops Julie I mean
I I don't care I just can't decide if
it's bad you tell me why people should
stop Julia and then and then I'll assess
the facts but right now like it's taking
a place of cigarettes
oh okay someone Jerome a bro they're so
popular because the amount of nicotine
in a jewel is three times the amount of
like other ecigs what yeah of other
easiest a lot of cigarettes okay okay
that's that's good to know and nicotine
is addictive Jordan good when I smoked
five cigarettes a day until I got a
jewel and then I never had one again
Wow that's good right I don't know right
now
Mogi is so cocky much to do more
research but from the things I know
right now I'm Pro jewel your pool I'm
free because honestly we see legs
everyone in the world to stop smoking
completely it's unrealistic so to move
from cigarettes which are terrible to
joules which are a lot less bad they're
not good for you but they're less bad
that's great I did it just the right
direction at the end of the day no one's
forcing you to smoke and you want to
smoke it's your own decision and great
you want like you know it's always we
don't know what happens to you when you
smell you you want to smoke great I
don't care you know it's all you don't
know it's not like you think they're
good for you then you find out they give
you cancer like it's written on the
package now when you put them in your
mouth you know that they give you cancer
and you find that so cool good for you
makes it
it's your life kill it no ever make
certain decisions like I can't be
bothered with other people like right
look at the government trying to like
tell people to stop smoking like it's
their personal decision right and like
someone else smoking like does not
affect me whatsoever
same except like consuming in the sixth
grade that's yeah and like Julie you
shouldn't be marketing towards teens cuz
like that's a little [ __ ] up but
that's like any that's like anyone
marketing towards teens alcohol
cigarettes etcetera except alcohol
they're like they have so many rules
against them you can't even like
protocol you can't have a commercial on
TV with someone taking a sip of the
alcohol that you're selling you can't
have I mean I worked on like I don't
know what the rules of TV are but like
for social you can't be holding any
alcohol it's someone in the picture it's
not 21 you cannot be you can't have two
cups in either hand you can't have more
than like say if you have a picture of a
beer it can't be Hannah be full like
it's like a marketing thing
yeah it saved the most crazy rules
yeah and that's the FDA and that's you
know anything you watch Mad Men the
whole cigarette like they're good but
now it's like two cigarettes even have
commercials now no they have um it's
just so funny and like because this is
so American whereas like in other
countries like in Israel where like
smoking is very much a part of the
fabric of the culture like nobody gives
a [ __ ] like they have other things to
worry about besides likes smoking
killing you well though actually fun
fact yesterday Israel banned the
importation of dual pods like oh why
because I think it's because kids
yeah well because everyone there was
just like say your jewel in both hands
that's so yeah because they want they're
not using jewels to get off of
cigarettes they're just doing both yeah
right that's funny that isn't like in
Europe like they don't like like
Americans are just so like see Aaronson
ban bring in but like in your up they're
like who cares yeah I'm so much more of
that mentality like I'm not like here's
the thing everybody knows that drugs are
bad for you but people still wanted to
it great it's a personal decision who am
I to judge your bad decision making like
that's in your life me I'm not gonna do
drugs because I know that they're bad
food I'm not really interested in it but
someone else they know it's bad and they
still want to do it great like great so
just don't bite my face off yeah that's
all I ask
though my face people are talking about
third hand smoke like I've heard a
secondhand smoke i but third hand i have
yet to hear no but i guess - oh let's
get rid of secondhand smoke because I
think blowing protons in someone's face
isn't nearly as bad it's like not as bad
as just sitting on your computer with
protons on your lap exactly radiating
protons anyways you guys it's such a
good call we'll keep you posted on the
story I'm definitely gonna do more
research but jewels are taken over visit
final story a little bit of sports news
for you little sports business finance
giants Odell Beckham jr. becomes the
highest-paid NFL wide receiver ever with
a five-year 95 million dollar contract
extension with 65 million guaranteed
mm-hmm is that crazy that yes and it's
like you would think he's like so good
and the Giants are winning well he is so
good in the Giants we're waiting for a
long time with him I'm not like in the
past like two years I think but he does
the thing where he catches it with one
hand okay
I think he was also there when Eunice
was beating up someone viola I don't
think we ever got to talk about that
video because it was the day you left
right he was
we never talked about that video footage
security footage was released of Delilah
a nightclub where Eunice was with this
big group of people including Drake and
Odell Beckham jr. and he literally
started beating the [ __ ] out of this
poor like guy who worked there and I
don't know what led up to it like the
guy probably said something now see
whatever he did he couldn't give him the
table and they wanted whatever he did it
obviously was not worthy of the beatdown
like that but Odell and Drake were both
there and Drake ran away that videos
like so embarrassing for Drake like I
can't believe that there were so many
people watching this horrible thing
happened and not one person said
anything like that is just so classic
Hollywood totally evil people and now
all this is making sense with Courtney
like she was like when that when he did
that comment on Instagram like that was
a really like if you could just brush
that off but like that's also a really
concerning thing to say like and may be
indicative of like really manipulative
controlling relationship and it's like
it's one thing to like say it and then
it's another thing to post it on
Instagram to her 60 million followers
and it's like not only do you think that
that's a good no okay thing to say it's
like you're proud of it and you want
people to know that that's how you feel
right so I think that was like a huge
red flag and now that this is happening
like not really surprised by it and all
this Kardashian stuff that we're seeing
now like a couple months later it's like
starting to make sense right because
she's clearly like uh not well done yeah
not rubbish uh anyways I really like
that video was so sad and I expected
more from obj and Drake but I guess they
like didn't want to get their hands
dirty cuz like they have a lot on the
line whereas unis like all he has is
like had you know it was Courtney's
Instagram and trips to Italy there was a
rumor a while ago very briefly that
zendaya and Odell Beckham jr. rotating
and I was like so here for it like how
cute so here for it and like I think
they took a picture together in a
fashion show and I don't think they were
really ever dating or they might have
went on a date and I don't think it
worked out because India is literally
too good for everyone
truly except for that guy from but I
always feel like I like one sense India
up who would you set her up with like
obviously I'm in my wildest dreams so
down Beckham jr. is that guy from but he
was in love with her and I don't think
she was interested I look that's the
thing I really can't think of someone
who's good enough for zendaya yeah I
don't think it could be an athlete and I
don't think it could be an actor because
they lie and I don't think it can be
someone her own age cuz she's so wise
sure and like what Mario she
is dating Tom Holland her the Superman
co-star who literally looks like a boy
you remember I don't know how that I
whatever well there's all these blinds
Nick fully cheats on her and it's really
sad what yeah oh my god isn't it deserve
so much there's a special place in hell
for people who cheat on zinnia yeah
the one guy he did know I just like love
zendaya she's so in tune with like her
age demographic and she's just like oh
he's sharing memes and like taking right
choices in like she was on shake it up
Chicago with Bella Thorne and it's like
she could have gone that way but she
went this way I think the route that she
took after Disney was like a very
untraditional one where like she didn't
really work a lot she was very in the
fashion scene and like they used to talk
about her on fashion police but the
utmost respect until until they didn't
that's what made fashion police crumble
it is a a thing when giuliana rancic
said that she's probably like I guess
she smelled like patchouli yeah that was
about Sandhya and that's what brought
the whole thing down good oh my god I
didn't know it was about our Queens and
day huh yeah
nothing it's okay to say it about anyone
but oh my god honestly that chilled was
a sinking ship
wait did that happen with Joan no okay
obviously stolen so Giuliana said it and
there was backlash and Kelly like
demanded an apology Kelly turned on
Giuliana so there was just all this
animosity plus like the show was never
what it was with Joan so we need to shut
it down
yeah no that's a terrible thing to say
and I love zendaya so it's an even more
terrible thing to say but before that
they used to talk about her like and I
really understand why they were like
literally talking about her like she was
this fashion model icon because she was
like that girl from shake it up but she
really like she pulled it together and
then she started working like a couple
years later but she really for a while
was just like a socialite yep also
low-key she had her own show on Disney
after shake it up about like the AC yeah
being a CIA person that no one ever
heard of except like Disney people watch
it so she like was building a really big
fan and she went back recently and
started the show again I don't know if
it's still on but like she took a break
from Disney and then went back to that
show KC undercover yeah and honestly I
just love people who embrace their roots
like people who hate the thing that made
them famous I will always say like I
hate that like how much have perfect
example right like that's I hate when
people just don't embrace the thing she
does because she sings the
she's singing on her live stream before
younger came out okay younger now and I
feel like she is she's back she's back
she's back but and i'm i didn't
understand i might like took her a while
get there but it's more so like the
people from the OC who like won't talk
about it like they want Ben McKenzie to
talk about Gotham like we didn't even
what that is we want to talk about the
OC Ryan Wright his name will never not
be Ryan Atwood yeah with this dad Frank
totally Nietzsche no I remember when
there is the major Powerball win where
we all bought tickets it's the biggest
jackpot ever and then the winner came
from Chino California nursing home and
he gave a lot of money to it like the
families of his City yeah he was like
this really nice Jewish guy who won like
that's another thing that like I love
when like the whole world it's like
we're all like the power is like
bringing us together the Powerball
what's it from Noah Ritter yeah my
grandpa watches the Powerball yeah no my
god honestly I really hope no were to
have Ritter has like a good amount of
money from his fame and I hope that he's
like kickin it with Missa Ramsey he's
being taken care of by Ellen cuz he
still does ellentube and he was on a
Purina commercial uh-huh and Ellen
really took care of him
so I appreciate her for that I'm like
mad at her for so many things these days
there is a huge billboard on Second
Avenue when you cross the aisle in the
Midtown Tunnel and it's Ellen and she's
like trying to pick up this huge heart
and it said big heart wait no it said
like big laughs big heart and I
literally want to take a sharpie and
write big [ __ ] she's like I think about
that all the time because she is like
she gets away like yes she is this
iconic and she is and I love her and I'd
love her show and I think that her the
creative first show is brilliant but
like lest we not forget she is a huge
[ __ ] like we also that that ad even if
she makes a seminar it should say big
laughs bigger heart now I couldn't agree
more I never thought about this money
and then I would write biggest [ __ ]
like I hate this room big laughs bigger
heart biggest [ __ ] literally like if
there is a vandalization of that
billboard it just know that it was me
what you interested uh if you get caught
like honestly I feel like that would be
like a really good PR thing for the show
but not if I get fined and have instead
of writing Ellen for big heart big
laughs right the morning toast no no I
would write big [ __ ] yeah I wouldn't
even promote our show but like then I
would obviously
yeah like a little press because I'm the
girl who birthed a billboard and then I
was like I would post a picture of the
billboard on my Instagram like I didn't
want to be like alright this is
hysterical who did it right and then I
would really get mad but whoever smelt
it dealt it totally I mean that's the
most obvious thing you could do like who
is this who did this whoever denied it
supplied it whoever did the crime pays
the time I know yeah whatever no matter
watch arms in ubach last night I finally
finish it marker did you finish the
season no I haven't finished it was so
terrible and I've been watching it like
while shopping for furniture like not
even watching but the last episode was
amazing Margo spoiler alert pepper gets
outta prison not gonna watch it that's
true I'm not how do you reckon about you
and it's like she got early release it
was the craziest thing ever and she gets
out with this girl who has been like
trying to get pregnant with her
boyfriend and they're like so cute I was
like talking to get to each other in
Spanish and like I love them he's like
this big fat guy they're so cute she a
new character no but she was on and
she's like irrelevant but now she's
relevant and it was so sad literally her
and Piper get out together and they go
out separate doors and the girl who was
like trying to meet her boyfriend gets
deported because she was the leak like
illegal on her husband's waiting with
flowers and he never comes and it was
like so sad and like she got on this
like bust like i seee ice it was so
upsetting and like paper like just gets
to leave with her like that brother like
it was just it was so not fair like I
was so angry no way to I don't know that
that's how the episode ended she's
definitely coming back I mean the show
was less and less about her which I like
because she sucks but the show has just
gotten out of control like there's way
too many characters way too many plot
lines like [ __ ] Carol and the sister
so stupid honestly the bigger space my
time I think I'm done with it so if I
want to seem like Piper had a whole life
when she came into jail like she had a
fiance a life a business a friend family
literally she caught off all four ties
she's engaged Alice and the brother was
only person who came to pick her up
because he like lives in the trailer I
don't watch do you are you caught up
with Kardashians emotionally yes I'm
always keeping up with a car but the
show no oh really yeah and watch this
week um I watched last night I caught up
with everything and they're back to like
their usual [ __ ] of like doing pranks
and Chris trying to make Chloe eat while
she's pregnant but there were like a few
golden moments that was just so telling
what's really go subplots are so stupid
sometimes so stupid except I'm loving
the friendship between Khloe and Kim
it's everything I did not know that I
needed because all along like it's been
Khloe and Kourtney and they like ganging
up on Kim cuz like she is the favorite
and obviously the most successful but
now like Khloe and Kim they're so like
cute together and funny and they're just
like vibing and Kourtney and Kendall are
like misery I can't believe Kendall's on
Team Corday look I can literally so
similar and they're just and they keep
talking about how Cora like Kim and
Khloe are like mean and on how we're
like I don't even know where all the
meanness is coming from but like they
literally have never seen me better
right but Kim has never seemed better
thriving is literally getting everything
that she wants yeah it's like it's not
even about Tristan like I feel like
Khloe just wants to be a mom and like
thankfully she has a baby daddy that
like she doesn't need to take care of
right who can supply for the cup for the
kid a college fund right and like she
gets a beautiful child I couldn't agree
more that's why I like guess people are
upset with Tristan Khloe like I am too
but like whatever she just wants a
family and like sometimes you gotta like
not all families are the same know each
other I'm just got to do annoying things
to get what you want
totally and then she couldn't like the
fact that she could get pregnant with
Tristan is a miracle because obviously
she could've got pregnant with Lamar cuz
we known it now know like his sperm had
crack in it but even before that she her
she wasn't ovulating if she had
fertility issues like fer didn't have
even been able to get pregnant is
America is amazing and it's a miracle
I'm like whatever
totally like I said her own bad
decisions like I will no longer be like
I have enough on my plate like I will no
longer be inundated with like stress
about other people's poor decision
making like it's not my problem anymore
also when Kourtney is talking to Kendall
and they're being like shady [ __ ] and
she's talking about she told Kendall how
Kim said that she's the least
interesting to look at and Kourtney was
like do you see what people on the
internet say about me versus her that
she has cellulite all over her ass like
it was so mean Kourtney's obviously the
type of person when she gets mad like
she says unforgivable things I'm like
I'm sane and think what Kim said was
that bad but I saw a clip of Kourtney
saying that and I was like oh my god
especially because Kourtney was with her
in Mexico when those pictures came out
that were so horrible and like really
upsetting and so you know that's
literally her biggest biggest security
like there's all that going down
family oh I mean I'm so invested in this
I really really [ __ ] hate corny like
with as if she was like my own friend
yeah I and like Scott has never been
better he seems so happy and I think
that's also making her crease like so -
Scott was always waiting in the wings
wanting to get back together and now
he's literally dating like the younger
newer Kourtney they look so similar so
similar it was looking more like each
other every day right except like Sophia
seems to be like fun and like down for
Scott's lifestyle I mean the blinds say
a few other things but you know what
Hollywood nothing like nothing is yes
like every she's everything is shady
that lead astray is our friend Danny
it's Drake up yeah she's a Drake Cup
like her face is saggy and she's always
just like not saggy like old like saggy
just like it takes breakups to frown
which she's always doing yeah so like
and she had a the life of Riley for a
long time because she was making a lot
of money she'd have to work and she had
a guy who was [ __ ] obsessed Aaron
only want to do was have sex with her
and she would say no but like once every
couple years would say yes and then
happy a like she's had a relatively easy
life but now it's like your sisters are
finally calling him out for the fact
that you don't work you don't have a man
who's obsessed with you you have a man
who like yells and controls you and and
spends your money first sure totally at
the gym and like oh my god and it's like
you're always taking trips but like
she's she's funding those trips of
course and it's also so funny because
you see like I kind of understand on the
way the show works now it's like they
have to make the schedule filming it's
not like we're all just happened to be
hanging out and there's a camera and
that's what is confusing that they don't
really say it's like we have to work but
work is then like sitting and leading up
yeah you bring making something out like
Kim being a mortician like yeah that was
pretty stupid but I think I was cracking
up when Kim is in Khloe's kitchen and
Khloe stalking Min Ho she does money
gained a lot of weight which by the way
was like so relatable and I love the way
they talk about two-way meeting shoes
because it's so real and like yeah
pregnant people shouldn't be worried
about gaining weight but like I'm sure
they are totally so when Kim was like
you have to get out of the house and Kim
was like I will never forgive myself for
this moment where she it's a picture
that like was horrible she's so big she
was like I have a neck girl I'm wearing
Havaianas because I can't fit it she was
like what's the picture what was she
wearing oh my god just search Kim
Kardashian like pregnant like it's like
so many was her first pregnancy before
she like got it right Kim Kardashian
before she got the bodycon and the
kimono no but remember her first
pregnancy where's that that mean we're
like she was free willy they called her
that was so mean and that's why she
doesn't smile for the paparazzi and she
was wearing Havaianas did you know that
cuz they were so mean to her during her
present pregnancy she doesn't smile
that's why she's never smiling oh my god
that is so sad what kind of alpha was
she wearing she was wearing like a dress
below the knee that was like really
tight and what color just her to be
searched havaianas it's like oh no heavy
on us it was it's gray coming up
let me see she's wearing like a black
blazer well posted on Instagram it was
just like a style this is like such a
mean thing to be googling and like I
just people are so me and I tell like
Kim googled it to pull up the picture
Chloe she was like I was stepping out
like this and like you don't even have a
bump yet right that's straight no Chloe
and Chloe looked really good the whole
time yeah so did Kylie it from what we
saw but it was so interesting when Chloe
was like I'm a big person interesting as
a big person like our baby's gonna be
big and like it's if it's super made
like I have to have a c-section like I
didn't know that was a thing oh look a
baby can be too big a baby could be too
big and especially if the parents are
both big interesting yes so that's why
her doctor was like I don't want to
deliver her like a big baby so like you
you can't gain that much weight like 30
like yeah they came gained 70 pounds
during her pregnancy I'm so worried cuz
like you know I'm gonna be in like a
hundred I think I will gain 70 pounds I
think like my body she was just not like
those girls who like from the back don't
look pregnant they turn around they had
like a perfectly round basketball under
their belly you know like my everything
about me is gonna change you know
looking forward to it yeah like Bethenny
really her face changed a lot also what
was so interesting is they're sitting
around talking about like being pregnant
not drinking and I feel like for so long
the family never drank and now they do
that's like every family and Kim TLAs
let but now they're like 40 and they
just started okay Kim was like I was
talking to Christy and Christy was
saying she's pregnant she's so bored cuz
she can't drink oh he was like literally
same like everything in life is enhanced
yeah I was like that they never they
never drank or talked about drinking so
like I just love watching them at house
yeah and like I don't know the way that
the Kardashians just like embrace the
fact that they're not naturally born
like skinny people like they really do
like to eat which I believe like the way
Kim talks about food like those
croissants
I mean not Benes
New Orleans and the Cheesecake in Paris
like that I love cuz that's like so
relatable and you just think like all
these people who are famous like we're
just born skinny and like it's so hard
no one even kimchi they also all the
working out stuff is like starting to be
annoying because like works out with her
bodybuilder every morning and she really
wanted to get Chloe out of the house so
she took her out at night to go like TP
Chris's house and also they went to
Domino's and like Chloe's just living in
Kim's eating Domino's with her and
they're in the car like being hungry so
cute anyway so okay we need Kourtney
Khloe and Kim to in Calabasas yeah where
should they go
they should go somewhere yeah I'm like
hey Khloe has a newborn so like we need
like a couple let me be a year right but
they should wear haven't they been
they've got everything should they go
down a lane for a while that would be so
I can be like so anonymous totally so
what's Chloe's deal she's like living in
Cleveland I believe so but I think she's
back and forth like has basketball
season started in real life ya know so
she's probably in LA yeah it starts like
in October but she gave birth in
Cleveland so she was there for a while
interesting and she just like likes that
life she does she comes back to LA to
work and to fill the morning handy to
drive down right what is it where's
Cleveland in the country like map like
middle sort of middle east okay Margo
that's a joke we need in Raleigh
Cleveland's in the Middle East
yeah so is wrong it's like middle of the
country a little cream right yeah that's
a long flight that's not like you know
know as far as New York know what in
Dallas was further yeah
Dallas la is equally down is equidistant
to New York and LA nobody saying what's
further Dallas or something yeah after
line is farther I believe it sucks yeah
but I think probably like one more hour
yeah and then when you're on the private
jet who cares right we need a private
jet
I know fun I know let's get on it yeah
well maybe we're one step closer since
the most amazing wonderful and fantastic
toasters so that our merge like honestly
multiple times like we are so grateful
like the toast is the greatest show but
like it's nothing if nobody watches it
so everyone who watches and engages and
is in a Facebook group and makes a
friend and goes to a meet-up advise a
shirt like it's all part of this like
big family and really we're so grateful
so thank you guys for just coming out
and supporting it means a lot and like
we really couldn't like we're
conservative in our estimates because
like you never want to break in right
where they have but we
we knew the choice would show up for us
right I didn't expect in the way that
they did like I'm so excited to see the
numbers but anyways thank you guys so
much I'm sure that mercy like we got
merch to you it sold out we're so
grateful and now we could just take
those funds and reinvest in like high
quality ass [ __ ] like I will like rock
and roll merch like you were so we need
some in Spokeo so yeah like Mason ran
like like just like cool t-shirts that
you could wear his dress is here to ship
designer email fall is upon us like
we're gonna get you swagged out if you
haven't got your ticket to camp toast
yet you still can up until September 4th
so if you go to our Instagram there's a
link that says get tickets just click it
it takes you to the Eventbrite page and
the password is in all caps premium
obviously and it's going to be a face
we're really excited about it thank you
guys so much for watching today anything
else no we will see you tomorrow for
preppy connection movie of the week
everyone watch including myself and your
toasters oh right ok so email to your
toasters at gmail.com if you have any
questions concerns some advice you need
on relationship stuff wedding stuff work
stuff whatever family stuff those can be
awkward let us know dear toasters at
gmail.com thank you guys so much for
watching the Millenial morning show the
morning show so Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern we go live on
Facebook and YouTube so make sure you
like us on Facebook and subscribe to us
on YouTube but if you're a commuter who
can't get to a computer in time commuter
computer make sure to subscribe to us in
the podcast app the morning toast or on
Soundcloud if you have an android follow
me at Jackie's problems I'm private now
so you have to request can't just lurk
no more inches I'm loving being private
I have to sound like confidence like
it's just like I could say whatever I
want
yeah but not really not know but like
it's nice this feeling I really good
thing to take a sip Tina
yeah I like it the only people with all
your like people who want to write and
the lurkers who are just coming to like
make fun of me a screenshot my [ __ ] like
now you have to follow me bye guys love
you have a good day
you